off, the state preparations, unitary gates, and measurements won't be performed directly as single gates or as
single cubit measurements or state preparations, but rather they'll be performed by so-called gadgets, which
could each involve multiple cubits and multiple operations. Here in this diagram, I've
illustrated this by drawing purple boxes around these things. And you can think of these purple boxes as being like little circuits or operations that are
merely labeled by whatever state preparation or gate we intend to implement. Second, we need to protect
the cubits using an error correcting code. So it won't be the logical cubits themselves that connect these different gadgets, but rather the gadgets act on
the physical cubits that encode these logical cubits. And it's worth stressing here that the logical cubits that we care
about are never exposed, meaning that these logical cubits will spend their entire lives being protected by whatever
quantum error correcting code we're using. And finally, we perform error correction on our encoded cubits
repeatedly throughout the computation, basically whenever we have a chance. And it's critically important that we do
this. Intuitively speaking, as errors take place, randomness or uncertainty starts to build up in the state of our
cubits and we need to constantly work to remove this randomness or entropy. And this happens through error correction.
So you can kind of think of these error correction steps as being like little logical refrigerators or heat pumps that
allow the logical cubits to stay cold so that the computation can work correctly.
Once all these choices have been made, meaning the selection of all the gadgets as well as the code and assuming a particular noise model, there's a
fundamental question that we can ask ourselves and that is, is this actually helping. Are we making things better or
are we making things worse? If there's too much noise, we could very well be making things worse,
just like the 9Q shore code makes things worse if the chance of an error is too high.
But if the noise is below a certain threshold, then all of this extra work will get us somewhere. And as we'll discuss toward the end of the lesson,
paths open up for further reduction of the error. In this part of the lesson, we'll discuss error propagation in fall
tolerant quantum circuits having the basic structure that I just described. This turns out to be a
primary concern because if we don't manage to control error propagation, errors will quickly overwhelm our error
correction efforts. But if we're able to control the propagation of errors, then our code will stand a much better chance
of keeping up so that errors can be corrected at a high enough rate to allow our computations to
work. The starting point for this discussion is the realization that two cubit gates or multiple cubit gates more
generally can propagate errors even when they function correctly.
For example, consider a C not gate. And suppose that an X error occurs on the control cubit prior to the C not gate
being performed. Well, an X error functions just like an X gate. And we find that
the circuit on the left is equivalent to the one on the right where X errors occur on both of the cubits after the C
knot. This is a propagation of errors because the unfortunate location of the X error on the left effectively turns it
into two X errors on the right. And we'll never get around this. As long as we use C not gates, there's always going
to be a chance that an X error occurs on the control cubit right before it, which then propagates to two X errors
after. But as we'll see, as long as we take steps to limit the damage that this causes, we'll be okay. And by the way,
the same phenomenon occurs when we have a Z error on the target cubit just prior to a C knot. And we discussed this
earlier and you can check these equalities by simply performing the multiplications or you can check them using
kisskit. The upshot is that this will in both cases cause correlated errors on multiple cubits. And of course we
shouldn't forget that the C not gates themselves could also be faulty which can also cause correlated
errors. Adding to our concern, subsequent two cubit gates might propagate these errors even further.
For instance, if we have three C not gates like this, just like we find when we're measuring Xstabilizer generators, for instance, then a single error can
quickly propagate to multiple cubits. And if this happens within a single code block, for instance, meaning a bunch of
cubits that together encode a logical cubit, whatever error correcting code we've chosen isn't going to stand a
chance because codes are designed to correct lowweight errors, not highway errors like this.
And so this is something that we have to keep in mind front and center in fact as we're thinking about the gadgets and the
error correction steps in fault tolerant quantum circuits. The simplest known way to mitigate error propagation in fault
tolerant quantum circuits is to implement gates transversally and I'll explain what that means
momentarily. So let's keep the figure of our fault tolerant cir implementation on the screen just as a visual aid.
The idea here is that for some quantum error correcting codes, certain gates can be implemented transversally, which
means implementing them using gadgets that are tensor products of operations where each operation acts only on a
single cubit position within each code block. This is easiest to explain through some examples. The first and
arguably simplest example is transversal implementations of polyge.
The idea is that we'd like to build gadgets for each of the gates in our circuit. And in all cases, those gadgets
operate on code blocks like we see for the X and Z gates at the end of our teleportation circuit. Of course, we
can't decode, apply a polygate, and then re-encode because that would leave a logical cubit unprotected and errors
might propagate within the code block as a result of re-encoding.
Fortunately, we don't need to do that as long as we use a stabilizer code because every stabilizer code allows for poly
operations to be applied directly to our logical cubits. And in fact, we can do that with a tensor product of poly gates
on the physical cubits used for the encoding.
For example, if we consider the 3x3 surface code that came up at the end of the previous lesson, then we can implement X and Z gates on the logical
cubit encoded by this code by tensoring together X and Z gates along with identity gates in the patterns that are
suggested here. This is a transversal implementation of these gates because every one of these individual gate
operations acts only on a single cubit position within each code block.